Laser-vision throat surgery to end the zombie
apocalypse?
Believe it or not, that's not even the weirdest
way a fight between Superman and Black Adam
has ended.
In the comics, Black Adam is not a sworn enemy
of Superman.
Regardless of The Rock's desire to see these
powerhouses trade blows on the big screen,
they don't actually have an official rivalry
with one another in DC lore.
Black Adam, originally known as Teth-Adam,
was called the Mighty Adam after the Wizard
Shazam bestowed on him the ability to say
"Shazam!" and gain all his power.
Unfortunately, Black Adam abused this power,
using it for selfish gain and then for evil.
Because of this, the Wizard imprisoned Black
Adam, vowing to wait for the right person
to come along and be his next champion.
"I was a slave until I died.
Then I was reborn a god."
Centuries later, Billy Batson is chosen to
wield the power of Shazam.
Because of this, Black Adam returns, hoping
to kill the boy and claim his powers.
In some versions, Black Adam also kills both
of Billy's parents, though, in the most recent
origin, he simply wants the full Shazam powerset
to himself.
Thus, Black Adam is traditionally the archnemesis
of DC's Captain Marvel, the hero more commonly
known today as Shazam and not to be confused
with Marvel's Carol Danvers.
Because of his ties to the magic side of the
DCU, Black Adam rarely engages with Superman,
who is vulnerable to magic.
Generally, Black Adam and Shazam are more
closely involved with the Justice Society
of America, and, as comic book readers and
moviegoers alike will know, Superman is a
part of the Justice League, a totally different
superhero team.
As a result, they mostly stick to their own
corners of the DC Universe.
However, these two big hitters have still
crossed paths on occasion.
Black Adam first battled Superman in issue
#58 of "All-New Collectors' Edition," a comic
series that often pitted DC characters who
might not normally fight against each other.
During this period in comic book history,
Superman and the Justice League's stories
took place in a world called "Earth-One,"
while the Marvel Family and Black Adam existed
in a world called "Earth-S."
The "S" is surprisingly not for "Shazam."
In this issue the first ever crossover between
the Man of Steel and Shazam's fallen champion
took place.
It all unfolds after Black Adam uses a spell
to disguise himself as Captain Marvel and
begins destroying Metropolis while posing
as Earth's Mightiest Mortal.
Superman tries to stop the fake Captain Marvel,
who then uses Red Sun Radiation, a weakness
of Superman's, to disarm and defeat the Man
of Steel.
Eventually, the real Captain Marvel returns
to Earth-One, but Superman, believing that
his former ally has gone rogue, attacks and
nearly kills Captain Marvel.
Seeing this take place, the Wizard Shazam
explains the situation to Superman, who apologizes
to Captain Marvel for the beatdown.
Black Adam, at the behest of Martian sorcerer
and scientist Karmang the Evil, plans to merge
the two worlds together in what could have
proven to be a cataclysmic event.
Thankfully, the duo of Superman and Captain
Marvel thwart Karmang's plan and send Black
Adam back to Earth-S together.
All in a day's work!
A few years later, Black Adam returned to
the main DC Universe of Earth-One in "DC Comics
Presents" #49, which hit shelves in September
1982.
In this issue of the famed DC team-up series,
Black Adam comes to Earth-One and attempts
to conquer the world, liking his chances because
it's a world without Captain Marvel.
He also hopes to defeat Superman again in
the process, but he knows it won't be a simple task.
As such, Black Adam decides to hold Earth
One's Billy Batson hostage and use him to
keep Superman from thwarting another one of
his plots.
"Now I kneel before no one."
Though Superman at first tries to talk Black
Adam down and handle things diplomatically,
the supervillain refuses to yield.
Instead of listening to reason, he engages
in an exceedingly dangerous battle with the
Man of Steel.
Like before, Black Adam begins to overpower
Superman due to the magical nature of his
abilities, but the Kryptonian has a trick
up his sleeve.
Superman manages to rescue Billy from Adam's
grasp and uses him to bring the Billy Batson
of Earth-S to Earth-One so he can join the
fight.
After a big battle involving Superman, Captain
Marvel, and Black Adam, the supervillain is
finally defeated.
How?
It's pretty simple, really: Earth-One's Billy
Batson tricks him into saying "Shazam!," stripping
him of his powers and returning him to human
form.
Captain Marvel then uses the few brief seconds
afterward to knock out Teth-Adam and keep
him from transforming into Black Adam again.
And with that, he says goodbye to Superman
and they return to their own world.
In the years that followed the Man of Steel
and Black Adam's second bout, Earth-One and
Earth-S, along with numerous other worlds,
were merged into a single New Earth that featured
Superman, Captain Marvel, and all of their
respective foes.
Black Adam was reformed into something of
an antihero and even joined Captain Marvel
in the ranks of the Justice Society of America
at one stage.
This wouldn't last though, and Black Adam
eventually associated himself with the Secret
Society of Supervillains, seeing it as his
best shot at protecting his people in Kahndaq.
In 2005's "Action Comics" #831, Superman once
again finds himself at odds with Black Adam,
who himself is trying to prevent Doctor Psycho
from killing people in Metropolis.
Black Adam, annoyed that he's been associated
with Psycho's crimes, engages in a pretty
lengthy battle with Superman.
The two appear evenly matched here as they
duke it out across Metropolis, but when Black
Adam shows little regard for the innocent
civilians around him, Superman gets even angrier.
"Heroes don't kill people."
"Well I do."
After nearly pummeling Black Adam into orbit,
Superman is forced to stop when Black Adam
turns his back on him, banking on the fact
that he's not only the Man of Steel but a
man of honor.
It's a gamble that pays off.
The fight comes to an end and the pair strike
a deal with Doctor Psycho: He will release
the citizens of Metropolis from his mind control
if Superman allows him to walk free.
Reluctantly, Superman agrees, though only
after Black Adam assures him that Doctor Psycho
will be punished for his actions.
This would be the last battle between Superman
and Black Adam in the mainstream continuity.
After Superman and Black Adam's New Earth
tussle, various "Crisis" events took place
across the DC continuity, changing the powers,
origins, and even the personalities of numerous characters.
In the New 52 continuity, Black Adam briefly
fought an evil version of Superman from another
Earth named Ultraman during an event called
"Forever Evil."
This scrap doesn't end well for Black Adam,
with Ultraman crushing his jaw and leaving
him unable to speak the magic word "Shazam!"
Though he eventually heals, he is left humiliated
by the resounding defeat.
After the DC Rebirth rebrand, Black Adam encountered
the Man of Steel on several occasions, including
briefly in the "Doomsday Clock" limited series
and in the "Endless Winter" crossover event,
where he swore revenge on Superman after the
hero stopped him from killing the Frost King.
However, his frustration with Superman would
be short-lived, as the Man of Steel would
invite Black Adam to "turn over a new leaf"
and join the Justice League.
Hoping for some fresh perspectives, Superman
thinks that Black Adam joining the League
would be good for everyone involved.
It's a bold move that pays dividends, as Black
Adam learns to once again be the Mighty Adam.
Though Black Adam doesn't battle Superman
all that often in the mainstream DC Universe,
there are a few different alternate realities
in which these two powerhouses face off against
one another.
In 2020's "DCeased: Hope At World's End,"
a zombie-like Anti-Life Virus begins infecting
people across the world.
Hoping to contain the virus and its spread,
Black Adam begins using lethal force against
his own citizens in Kahndaq.
Unfortunately for Adam, he gets infected by
the disease at the moment he goes to invoke
the name of "Shazam!," making Black Adam one
of the undead.
Naturally, Black Adam infects his entire nation
and leads them toward global domination.
In response, the Justice League sends Superman,
Martian Manhunter, Green Lantern, and Cyborg
to stop Black Adam.
While his horde of zombies manages to escape,
Superman and his team nearly defeat Black
Adam before he recognizes their tactics and
retreats himself.
Eventually, Superman uses his heat vision
to sever Black Adam's vocal cords so he can
no longer use the magic word "Shazam!"
It's brutal, but necessary under the circumstances.
Though Superman and Shazam rarely share screen
time in animation outside of shows like "Justice
League Unlimited" and "Young Justice," they
did share top-billing in a DC Animated Original
where they fought against Black Adam together.
That film is "Superman/Shazam!: The Return
of Black Adam," which retells the story of
how Billy Batson first gained the powers of
Shazam.
In it, Black Adam returns to Earth to find
the Wizard's new champion, and decides to
take the power for himself.
When Black Adam shows himself, Superman works
to stop him from killing young Billy, and
the two battle across the Metropolis skyline
until Billy gains his Captain Marvel powers
and helps the Man of Steel take down his nemesis
for good.
This short proves that while Superman and
Black Adam aren't traditional adversaries,
there's certainly an appetite to associate
them with one another inside DC.
Outside of this short film, Black Adam and
his dog Anubis recently appeared in the final
post-credits scene of "DC League of Super-Pets,"
where they encountered Superman and his dog Krypto.
"Your owner's a hero too?
Anti-hero.
It's basically exactly like a regular hero
except way cooler."
Between that and the "Black Adam" movie, it
seems like DC is trying hard to ignite a rivalry
between these two on the big screen.
In the epic cinematic trailer for the massively
multiplayer online game "DC Universe Online,"
the Justice League battles members of the
Secret Society of Supervillains.
In a shocking turn of events, the Society
begins to overpower and kill members of the League.
After hearing the cries of his teammates,
Superman arrives to fight the Society, easily
taking down supervillain after supervillain
in the process.
One of them is Black Adam, who barely manages
to hold his own against the Man of Steel.
The 2013 fighting game "Injustice: Gods Among
Us" features Black Adam as a member of the
evil Superman's global group Regime, which
has taken over the planet to "keep it safe."
As a member of the Regime, Black Adam runs
various errands for Superman, at least until
a good Superman from another world arrives
and quickly defeats him.
In the sequel, "Injustice 2," Black Adam is
a major player, working alongside members
of Superman's Regime and Batman's Insurgency
to stop Brainiac from destroying the planet.
Elsewhere, the evil Superman tussled with
Black Adam in the pages of the companion comic
book series to the "Injustice: Gods Among
Us" video game franchise, too.
The DC Extended Universe started in 2013 with
Zack Snyder's "Man of Steel" and went on to
have varying levels of success, depending
on the project.
Henry Cavill made his debut as Superman in
that film and would reprise the role in 2016's
"Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice," 2017's
"Justice League," and, of course, 2021's "Zack
Snyder's Justice League," the director's cut
of the critically bashed team-up movie.
By far Earth's strongest protector, Superman
has battled alien invaders, monsters, and
even gods from other realms, making him a
formidable opponent.
As a founding member of the Justice League,
Superman works alongside the DC Extended Universe's
most impressive heroes, but none of them can
match him in terms of power.
However, now that Black Adam is on the scene,
there's a being who can potentially do just that.
"Your magic is weak."
Superman, played once again by Henry Cavill,
appears at the end of "Black Adam" with hopes
of talking to the titular antihero about his
presence in the DC Universe, and there's no
doubt that this thread will lead to some interesting
places.
What is a little strange is that it seems
as though there are no plans for Black Adam
to face his comic book nemesis, Billy Batson,
any time soon.
With Superman making cameo appearances in
both "Shazam!" and "Black Adam," maybe the
Man of Steel will be the bridge that brings
these classic enemies together on the big screen.
Whatever the future holds for the rivalry
between Black Adam and Superman, we're excited
to see what comes next and how these two powerhouses
will interact with each other.